dann spürt man manchmal sogar noch
diffus dies ist rücken den druck auf
brustkorb
das ist sehr nett dass sie mit uns
sprechen dass sie sich entschlossen
haben mit uns dieses interview zu führen
jetzt steht ja der zehnte jahrestag der
loveparade-katastrophe kurz bevor
gibt es bei ihnen so eine art ritual am
jahrestag
es ist ein komisches gefühl immer je
mehr monate rücken desto nervöser wird
man man also für mich ist das so es ist
so als würde ich weder diesen instinkt
bekommt was stimmt er mit irgendwas aber
man weiß es ja das ist schon längst
vorüber aber bald ist es soweit und
irgendwie uns und nervöser ist man umso
mehr ans wasser gebaut man isst man
kommt es ihnen so vor als wären diese
zehn jahre sehr schnell oder ihr sehe ja
sehr schnell zumal ich sehr lange
gebraucht habe wieder hier und jetzt zu
sein
ich habe vor vier jahren angefangen mein
beruf als ausbildung zu machen
davor war sechs jahre und diese sechs
jahre kann ich sagen das ist so
wo war ich denn da meine seele war
irgendwo weg mein körper ist wann war ja
also ich bin irgendwie neben meinen
körper belaufen
ich war und auch jetzt so zum teil manch
weiß es noch so wo man denkt was
wirklich passiert also man ist wirklich
neben der spur
man kann sich man kann das nicht in
worte fassen aber es ist so als wenn
meine seele meinen geist neben mir und
mein körper hier nur die hülle wissen
sie wenn wir so ein bild was man kennt
wie man sich den tod forscht etwa wenn
die seele rausspringt aus dem körper so
kann man sich das vorstellen
so legt man aber weiter ich laufe hier
und jetzt gerade direkt nach der
katastrophe war das so ich laufe durch
die stadt
es ist aber als würde ich gar nicht
laufen als welchen ganz an
dimension gewesen außerhalb was mein
körper
ich habe mich immer gewundert warum
menschen mich immer so angucken
ja mich immer ganz komisch angeschaut
jetzt habe ich gelernt damit umzugehen
es ist so wie jetzt würde man eine
facette aufsetzen das zeigen was die
menschen mittlerweile sehen wollen was
wollen die leute sehen dass was man
heutzutage ist dass man das vergessen
hat dass man damit gleich darum gegangen
ist die leute möchten gerne dass es
vorbei ist und dass sie sich mehr nicht
mehr darunter leiden nicht darunter
leiden
die haben es nicht miterlebt die kunst
nicht nachempfinden wie wir uns
empfinden videos fühlen
für dieses so mein gott heute schon
wieder rum das ist das so lange vorbei
für mich ist es so für viele anderen
auch so für meine schwester ist es auch
so als er dieser katastrophe nie vorbei
die wird doch nie vorbei sein
da können noch weitere ca die zeit wenig
oder gar nicht ein
es hilft zum beispiel damit man lernt
damit umzugehen man lernt damit wirklich
zu sagen okay aber der schmerz
die erinnerungen man sagt diese
sogenannten trigger situation
die kommen noch durch nichts ja die
kommen durch gerüche durch geräusche
durch situation bedenkt aber die können
noch so aufkommen
urplötzlich man fährt auto ist auf
einmal doch das stimmt da war doch was
genau so war das doch und dann was macht
man wenn man dem moment wieder drin ist
dann sagt kommen rosalinda in meinem
fall reißt sich zusammen versucht dich
zu konzentrieren fokussieren
man lebt weiter werden sie denn bereit
uns zu schildern wie sie diesen tag
erlebt
[Musik]
es sollte eigentlich ein spaßiger tag
seiner schwester duisburg duisburg ganz
in der nähe die strecke von den gleisen
die mussten wir zu fuß runter läuft
alles gesperrt war hat ein mann weiß ich
noch
er hat angefangen auf der ampel zu
klettern dann saß dann eine ampel
ich sagte zu meiner stößt in jujuy guck
mal was macht denn eine ampel der sitzt
da wir fanden das lustig wir hatten
schon die musik von weiten wir gehen
durch den tun wir alles war gut ich
glaube wir waren 13 uhr noch was war da
wir wollten da hoch laufen und da sind
wir auch aber es ist alles so abgesperrt
durch diese gitter davor wir konnten
nicht direkt zu der tribune tribüne hin
in meiner erinnerung bin ja nicht groß
ich bin ja 158 aber in meiner erinnerung
war das so wie sowieso ein labyrinth sah
das so aus die absperrung weil in jeder
hinter jeder absperrung waren menschen
die getanzt haben die glücklich waren da
oben wir um näher dran sein meine
schwester nicht und wir sind da zu
diesem berg hoch geklettert und vor
dieser absperrung da hätten
da ist der erste unglück passiert wird
das unglück da meine schwester hat sich
tief in die hand verletzt die hat sich
geschnitten an einer glasscherbe und das
war eigentlich so wir haben geguckt ob
die noch weiter blut das sie hat auch
weitere blute da habe ich zu meiner
schwester gesagt kommen wir gehen zum
sanitäter
wir lassen deine hand versorgen dann
kommen wir wieder zurückkommen also
zurück laufen wollen einmal gesehen die
polizei hat uns nicht vorbeigelassen
freizeit hat sich gerade vor uns
gebildet direkt vor uns nehmen uns immer
leute die haben gesagt wir lassen euch
gleich vorbei wir wussten nicht da die
haben gesagt leute wollten rein kommen
aber wir wollten raus kommen hinter uns
haben sich leute gestaut die an heraus
wollten
meine schwester hat mir die hand gegeben
hat zu mir gesagt das ziel arzt nicht
los dass auf keinen fall meine hand los
nahm rtl dann fingen die leute uns zu
drängen und verdrängen
irgendwann mal ist die polizei kittel an
sich gerissen war auch die gedrängt
worden sind von den menschen die rein
wollten
ich weiß nicht wie viel menschen
eingelassen worden sind keine ahnung
aber der druck war von hinten und von
vorne
eine schwester nichte von uns genau der
mitte wir wurden auseinandergerissen
wurden auseinandergerissen wir haben uns
aus den augen verloren
irgendwann mal hat meine schwester meine
stimme nicht mehr gehört weil ich sie
nach sie gerufen habe und ich habe sie
nicht mehr gehört es war so in dem
moment war es so warm als hätten wir
über 40 grad gehabt so viele menschen um
einen herum
die hatten alle die arme hoch gehabt ich
habe nicht verstanden warum wir die arme
hoch haben ich hatte ich habe immer
gesagt macht eure arme und ich bekomme
können luft ein besonderer junger mann
da hat mir geholfen dem moment weil ich
bin mir immer mehr hinein gesagt ich
konnte nicht mehr
ich habe keine luft bekommen ich bin ein
einfacher gesagt inzwischen dieser
menschenmasse ich hatte probleme gehabt
wieder hochzukommen war ja da war gar
kein platz mehr
der junge hatte man nicht mein vater
schon sie hat mich eine haare gepackt
und hat mir wieder hoch geholfen junge
hat zu mir und hat mir die ganze luft
gepustet
deswegen sollte macht ihr keine sorgen
ich hier raus schuldig hier wo es hat
mir gesagt hat er gesehen dass einer
treppengeländer da die leute rein und
raus versucht haben
ich bin gestolpert aber irgendwas ich
bin auf den dritten drauf gefallen
menschen fielen aus wert drauf
mädchen ab neben mir ich habe versucht
mit meiner rück nur noch die leute weg
zu drücken aber das hat nicht geklappt
das spürt man manchmal sogar noch diffus
dies ist den rücken den druck auf
brustkorb
wer weiß ich nicht mehr bin ich ich bin
im krankenhaus wachgeworden auf
intensivstation
keine ahnung meine schwester hat mich im
krankenhaus wieder gefunden
sie waren den beinen schwer verletzt
mir geht das mädchen nicht aus dem kopf
weil sie ein wunderschönes mädchen war
jung wunderschön blonde haare so schöne
blaue augen und ich glaube man hat mich
so schöne augen gesehen wie das mädchen
die hatte ja ich möchte ich bewegen
konnte davon ein kopf genommen ihr
zwischen ihrem kopf um meinen kopf
ich habe gesehen dass sie gestorben ist
diese bilder gehen nie wieder aus dem
kopf kommen
die bilder die man im fernsehen sieht
wie die leute hochklettern
ja das ist wahr aber das ist nur die
perspektive von oben die perspektive von
unten mittendrin zu sein ist ganz anders
ich spüre immer noch dass es so war wie
ein wellengang kann sich das gar nicht
vorstellen wirklich so wie wenn dieser
druck der menschen
sie sind dann im krankenhaus wieder
aufgewacht waren verletzt
ich habe nie verstanden was ich wirklich
hatte diagnosen
da kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen
aber ich weiß dass ich reanimiert worden
bin ich weiß nicht ob ich das verdrängt
habe ob ich das wissen wollte oder nicht
ich weiß es nicht doch bis heute nicht
wissen sie wen sie gerettet hat wäre sie
daraus gezogen
ich würde das ganz gerne ich möchte
diese person wiedersehen
ich weiß es leider nicht ich weiß dass
es ein junger mann war
ich hoffe dass ich diesen jungen mann
einmal sehen kann und mir einfach danken
zu können weil wenn er mich da raus
geholt hätte wäre ich schon längst tot
gewesen nicht zu toppen
wussten sie zu dem zeitpunkt als sie
aufgewacht sind oder danach in den tagen
danach wussten sie dass menschen
gestorben sind
auf der veranstaltung
nein weil ich zu dem zeitpunkt nicht
wusste ob ich überhaupt am leben bin
erst paar monate später
da wurde ich sauer auf mich selber warum
ich überlebt habe
warum das mädchen verstorben ist warum
konnte sie nicht auch leben wie ich oder
wochen konnte ich nicht mit versterben
dann sauer auf sich selbst und immer
noch warum
warum habe ich nicht geschafft sie zu
retten angesicht zu angesicht
zwei nebeneinander und sie fragen sie
sagte zu mir bitte hilf mir ein ganz
leiser stimme
ich habe es nicht geschafft
ich habe es nicht gesagt
kann denn bei ihnen irgendwann auch mal
gut auf also nicht auf sich selbst jetzt
in dem fall sondern auf andere leute
sagen vielleicht auf den veranstalter
dass die mit feuchten händedruck davon
gekommen sind
für mich ist das so die sind davon
weggekommen
wir sind die leidtragenden und die nicht
dass es nicht dass ich dem was wünschen
würde das ist es nicht das ist es
wirklich nicht ich bin mir sehr gläubige
person
es ist ungerecht wie es verlaufen ist es
ist uns gegenüber ungerecht wie die
hinterbliebenen also die hinter dem in
dem sinne die das überlebt haben wie mit
uns umgegangen wäre danach währenddessen
noch weiter zehn jahre später die wahre
hilfe so haben wir nur untereinander
trotzdem hat sich das in mein leben
verändert immer wieder tauchen engster
wie kein anderer das nachvollziehen kann
ich kann nicht mit ruhigen gewissen noch
für weihnachtsmarkt gehen habe ich
ständig die angst kommt oder kommen
menschen mehr entgegen da ist ein
beklemmendes gefühl und ich in der
branche aber das musste unter kontrolle
halten
du musst das unterdrücken wenn man
unterdrückt das aber warum kommt es hoch
ja klar ich habe nicht so viel therapie
gemacht wie die anderen aber das ist
weil mein therapeut zu mir am anfang
gesagt hat ich müsste meine kindheit
irgendwas auf und ich hatte eine
wunderbare kindheit ich kann nicht ich
kann nichts negatives darüber sagen ich
bin hier hingekommen um die luft bei zu
bearbeiten
wie ging das dann weiter buy
haben sie was haben sie vorher beruflich
gemacht und wie ging es danach weiter
also ich habe damals eine gaststätte
geleitet mein damaliger chef der kam so
kosmehl haus und hat mich besucht
irgendwann mal konnte ich damit nicht
mehr umgehen weil ich war nicht mehr ich
selbst ich habe keine ahnung ich war
nicht mehr ich selbst ich habe das dann
sein lassen nicht wahr dann wenn dann
arbeitslos gewesen habe vor mich hin
vegetiert sozusagen
irgendwann habe ich gedacht ich schaffe
dann habe ich durch meine mama hab ich
einen tollen beruf bekommen die mir die
chance gegeben hatten einblick in die
pflege zu geben
den habe ich dann auch gemacht
irgendwann habe ich eine bewerbung
geschrieben und dann habe ich dann halt
als krankenpfleger meine ausbildung
gemacht und den folge ich das war
das war 2000 als ich den beruf
angefangen habe 2016 das gerät was
gefällt mir diesen beruf gefallen nicht
das ist mehr interesse medizinische
aspekte zu sehen
eine fachabteilung ist neurologie was
passiert alles mit dem menschen mit dem
gehirn das gehirn ist ja der speicherort
und alles von den menschen und wie ich
ja schon ich weiß nicht ob ich das schon
ein wenig habe aber ich wünschte mein
schon mal könnte der kamera in dem
gehirn in hinein pflanzen und das zu
zeigen oder was man gesehen hat
das wollte ich auch ganz gerne an tag
meiner aussage vor gericht am liebsten
sogar mit gefühle wollte ich ihnen das
zeigen was hat man gesehen was hat man
dabei gefühlt weil erzählen es eine
sache erlebt zu haben ist eine andere
sache
sterben mit ersticken ist für mich das
schlimmste was es gibt
in dem moment hast du gar keine zeit zu
denken sondern bekämpft weil du kannst
du stirbst in angst du keine luft mehr
bekommst und irgendwann mal akzeptierst
du das dass du keine lust und bekommst
und restlos das ist körperlich und
seelisch
diese erfahrungen die durfte ich machen
weil die mich dann im konkurs wieder
zurückgeholt haben
sie waren dann eine der ersten oder die
erste zeugin vor gericht bei dem prozess
da mussten sie dann kapitulieren wie das
abgelaufen ist wie war das so sehen ich
weiß dass ich vor gericht die wahrheit
sagen musste wenn ich das nicht gewusst
hätte hätte ich kein wort gesagt weil
ich fühle mich so als hätte ich mich
offenbar ich habe sachen gesagt ich habe
mehr gesprochen
für dich eigentlich gar nicht bereit so
war und ich wollte auch nicht aber ich
musste es
ich musste den hier beweisen und sagen
wie es damals war
bist du schrecklich und ich würde das im
nachhinein würde ich das nie wieder tun
und wie haben sie dann den prozess den
weiteren gerichtsprozess und auch das
urteil
oder gab es ja nicht an die einstellung
des verfahrens
wie haben sie das alles weiter verfolgt
mir war klar dass das die schuldiger
sagen würden dass sie so davonkommen
würden mir war es klar für mich also so
als hätte ich den prozess verloren weil
ich nämlich mit 12.000 euro schulden
davon gekommen bin und ich frage mich ob
sarah oder sowas rechnung bekommen hat
deswegen habe ich auch gesagt ich würde
nie wieder aussagen unter anderem dass
es auch ein wichtiger aspekt werde ich
nicht mehr machen
auch da habe ich gelernt lieber schweige
ich als normal
manchmal das ist nun also wo man
gedanken wo man denkt ja hätten die mich
doch lieber sterben lassen sollen da
opfer treppe anstatt mich zu reanimieren
weil was hat dich denn davon
ich kann mit der welt nicht klar habe
jahre gebraucht um einigermaßen klar zu
kommen und jetzt klar versuchen ich bin
auf einem guten weg aber es ist nicht
das gleiche und da kam noch die
sahnehäubchen mit drauf mit den 12.000
euro da denke ich mir
darauf hätte ich locker verzichten
können jetzt ist ihnen geholfen denn da
jemand als schuldiger hingestellt würden
ja hat sich zwar harten aber ja auch
gerechtigkeit für die eltern ihre kinder
verloren haben
ich meine die haben ihre kinder verloren
die müssen mit den gleichen leid jedes
jahr an diesem datum mit unheimliche
ängste klar kommen und wie ihr leben
auch damit jedes jahr am 24 juli
sie sprechen von einzelnen menschen die
ihnen geholfen haben dieses kleine diese
kleine unterstütze blase hier in diese
welt auch um diesen lasten schwer zu
sagen
letztendlich bin ich diejenige die damit
klar werden muss da hilft auch kein
psychiater also bei aller liebe nichts
gegen den beruf oder so aber ich bin
diejenige die damit klar kommen muss am
ende am ende der stunde
entweder hat der feierabend oder hat den
nächsten patienten aber ich habe keinen
feierabend meine gedanken sind immer da
machen
mal mehr mal weniger mal schaffe ich
mich abzulenken mag ich hoffe ich jetzt
nicht abzulenken und dann verwandelt
sich das in andere gefühle mal ist es
einfach so lachen ohne grund mal ist es
wut aus heiterem himmel dann geht es so
wie in meinem fall ich arbeite da hab
ich zeit wie im fitnessstudio alles
rauszulassen alles viel auf die beine
hin hermann trägt die verantwortung
man muss hier die patienten
hundertprozentig da sein das ist
ablenkung kann dieses bedürfnis anderen
zu helfen auch erst nach dem ja weil ich
wissen wollte wie es mit ihren leuten
waren der uns geholfen haben aus dieser
situation
die ganze sanitäter die ganzen nicht
sanitäter die private leute sag ich
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich leute die mit
dabei waren haben andere leute
reanimiert ja akzeptiert ihr umfeld denn
dass es ihnen dann wieder schlecht geht
ja nicht alle aber ich habe so einen
tollen lebensgefährten an meiner seite
ich wünsche dir war von anfang an meiner
seite
das ist eine person der hat mir wirklich
nur einfach der liebe gott so geschickt
weil das sind so momente im leben wo man
sagt wow eigentlich ist es genau das was
wonach man herzlich die ganze zeit
gesehen hat und dann auf einmal hat man
diese person an seiner seite
da ist nichts mit aussehen oder so was
für die person ist einfach genau die die
wundervollste person auf erden
und das ist in dem fall halt mein
lebensgefährte unter anderem meine mama
auch oh gott meine mama ja meine
schwester oh ja das ist also meine
familie quasi eine und nebenbei halt
meine freunde und unterdessen auch meine
freunde von der love parade weil das ist
wie eine zweite familie und so ist es
auch
man kann
plötzlich du hast irgend was du
schreibst in der kindergruppe rheinbach
mir geht es nicht gut bums alle
antworten und alle antworten weil sie
genau das gleiche empfinden solche
freunde
die sind gold wert ich habe mein leben
akzeptiert ich habe lange gebraucht aber
ich habe mein leben akzeptiert aber ich
weiß dass ich weiterleben möchte ich
habe mittlerweile in diesen zehn jahren
habe ich jetzt zwei kinder ein
lebenspartner die nicht offenbar
irgendwann mal heiraten werde
und ich möchte weiter leben
ich möchte da weitermachen wo ich
aufgehört habe und es ist wert was tun
um mich vor angst um ihre kinder und
deren zukunft zu zerspringen
ich lasse sie leben die haben zwar
regeln aber ich lasse sie leben
meine kinder sollen von mir alles
ermöglicht bekommen wie es in meiner
macht so steht wie jetzt wenn mein sohn
er soll den roller führerschein machen
mit 15 jahren er hat sein mofa oder
moped auto wie das heißt er hatte schon
hier unten vor der tür schon stehen
desto länger mutigen sich frei zu fühlen
er soll sein leben genießen
es soll es für schön empfinden weil er
auch er hat darunter gelitten wie ich
gelitten habe nicht die richtige mama an
seiner seite zu haben wie es sein sollte
und so weiter nicht dass ich das wieder
gutmachen kann das kann ich nicht wieder
gut machen aber ich möchte ihnen
ermöglichen ein bisschen wieder
normalität zu bekommen um weiterzumachen
wie auch ich weitermache und das möchte
ich für meine kinder
ich möchte nicht in die pantoffeln von
den eltern stecken die ihre kinder
verloren haben weil ich kann es mir nur
vorstellen und mein herz zerbricht
haben sie das gefühl in den sohn und die
tochter vor verschiedenen situationen
auch schützen zu müssen oder ich kann
sie nicht vor allem schützen so sehr ich
das gerne möchte ich kann es nicht vor
allem weil auch wenn ich das verbietet
zum beispiel zur so eine veranstaltung
zu gehen weiß ich dass ob die das hinter
meinem rücken machen die können zu mir
sagt ich gehe zu meiner freundin kann
ich das nach beweisen
ich möchte dir auch nicht mit detektiv
möchte ich nicht ich möchte die
vertrauen und wenn es passiert bin ich
für sie da
egal in welcher situation ich bin für
sie da pläne in berlin wieder eine
nachricht zu veranstaltungen wie stehen
sie dazu
welche gefühle haben sie dabei wenn sie
das hören
gute gefühle warum nicht warum nicht nur
die sollen das nie wieder woanders
machen sollen die das in berlin lassen
wie es begonnen hat ich finde es gut ich
mag die musik ich möchte dich schon
immer ob ich noch mal da hingehen würde
nein wirklich nicht
würde ich nicht vielleicht von fernsehen
miterleben jahr aber persönlich da
hinein
[Musik]